[Applause]
how do you feel when you see willow sing
i think it's great i love when she sings
[Music]
she has you know your voice and both of
our athleticism
and that smile on pink's nine-year-old
mini acrobat
says it all the stunning mother-daughter
aerial performance of their duet cover
me in sunshine was without a doubt the
show-stopping moment of the billboard
music awards
[Applause]
think about where you were where you
came what you've been through in this
i think there's something to be said for
perseverance i've always told everyone
i'm like a rash i'm not going anywhere
and here i am
[Laughter]
pink hit the carpet with willow and her
four-year-old dapper little cowboy
jamison before her former crush jon bon
jovi presented her icon award
i did not come out of my room for a week
when you married dorothea
i was eight i ripped your poster off my
wall and i'm
very glad that you found lasting love
john but you broke my heart
started from the bottom now we're here
artist of the decade drake
also made it a family night he brought
adorable three-year-old son adonis on
stage to accept his award and
well cue the meltdown and to you i want
to dedicate this to you
no tears for the weekend after being
shut out of the grammys he swept the
night with
10 awards
[Music]
the after hours are done and the dawn is
coming
making good on his word the weeknd says
he's officially retiring his signature
after hours look
for good i'd like to thank god that i
don't have to wear that red suit anymore
thank you
we were with the night's other big
electric performers
[Music]
a lot of energy
high energy performance
it's a sort of compacted medley
kind of
[Music]
alicia keys also made it a medley to
celebrate 20 years since her first album
on the mend host nick jonas closed out
the show with a joe bros medley
and that won't be the last we see of
these three we're going back on tour
in august with our with our good friend
kelsey ballerini as our special guest
nick thanked wife priyanka for helping
him recover they got close on the black
carpet
though not as close as double winner
machine gun kelly and megan fox
mgk painted his tongue black and let's
just say these two were
all about the pda new mom and triple
winner gabby barrett had her fellow idol
alum turned hubby kate fainter
by her side too she takes care of me and
that baby and
thank you you know and then she gets out
here and does all this i mean she's just
there's no way nobody like her my son is
new friends yeah two months as for proud
papa and presenter leslie odom jr
he told us he's hiring nannies so he can
go film knives out too
in greece someone invites us to greece
we get we get an
invitation i might be saying too much
already
do you or does someone else wear a
chunky cable knit sweater
i hope it's me that's sweater iconic
[Music]
yes